you and I have something in common we
both owe a lot to Lauren Michaels
Michaels gave me my shot gave you your
shot
obviously iconic great man but let's
face it everybody who has worked with
Lauren we're all comedy performers and
we all when we get together all we do is
our Lauren Michaels impressions yeah and
you we and and everybody does them
everybody does everybody's yours is I
think one of my all-time favorites
because you put you got the voice down
of Lorne Michaels but you put a
particular spin on it yeah you get very
specific with you yeah yeah Lauren Fred
Armisen pointed out a thing that when
Lauren has to name-drop which he does a
lot cuz he knows like he know all of his
friends were super super famous he
always kind of rubs his eyes like this
like he's really put out by the amount
of famous people you know and so we
would do a bit John Solomon and some of
the writer with norm of Warren
name-dropping serial killers he goes to
restaurants to hang out and and with
famous people and famous others join him
yeah yeah yeah so like one would be like
I went to Kansas City with Alec and
Marcy to try to get me TK killer off
death row they said here comes BTK I go
you know his name is Dennis human be
like I was at Natanz E with Mick and
Jeffrey Dahmer
we had a we had this young man was our
waiter and he left and and Jeffrey said
I have to go to the bathroom I see of
course you do 1978 I was living with
Paul Simon and Ted Bundy cause we go
deeper with the serial killer yeah just
how dark is crowded I know this is a
really tough crowd
[Music]
[Applause]